الواسع فجرته تيك توكر اردنيه بعد قرار
خلع الحجاب عقب خمسه اشهر على ارتدائك
طبعا كما هو متوقع مشاهدينا وسائل الاعلام
الاجتماعي في الاردن ضجت باعلان تيك توك
ارسالي العوضي وسط اتهامات بانها تقصدت ان
تصبح ترند بما فعلته سالي ادعت بانها
تعرضت لحمله سب وشتم من قبل عدد كبير من
المتابعين وذكرت بان الكثيرين منهم تمنوا
لها الموت بسبب اتخاذها لهذا القرار
المثير للجدل في المقابل طبعا ظهرت سالي
البالغه من العمر 18 عاما في فيديو دون
حجاب قائله انها لن تسامح كل من ينتقدها
او يتنمر عليها واكدت انها غير قادره على
الالتزام بارتداء الحجاب لفتره اطول وانا
الحجاب مصدومين هلا بس
انا ما قدرت يعني ما قدرت على الحجاب يا
جماعه عشان الحجاب اموت صح عشان الحجاب
هيك عشان الحجاب بتدعو علي اموت اوكي طيب
يا سالي بدنا نعرف القصه بالضبط انت
تحجبتي قرار شخصي وبعدين قررتي انك تشلحي
الحجاب شو صار على السوشيال ميديا وشو
اكثر يعني انت معنا اليوم لانه حسيتي انه
في تنمر كبير عليك اشرحي لنا شو اللي حسسك
بهذا الشي
هلا كلهم عم بينتقدوني بطريقه يعني مش
انهم فيها نصح لا بطريقه كتير سيئه
بغلطوا في بحكوا حكي كتير سيء فهذا الشيء
اللي بحسسني انه انا عم بتعرض لهجوم كثير
كبير بحس انه دائما في اسلوب افضل للنصيحه
يعني مثلا تدعي لي تنصحني بطريقه افضل هيك
بحس افضل طيب خليني ارجع معاك شوي شوي الى
قرار اتخاذ انه انت بدك ترتدي الحجاب جاء
عن قناعه ولا انه جاء انه مع صديقاتك ولا
كيف هلا انا زيي زي
اي بنت تحجبت تماما بالضبط انا لما كنت
كتير مقتنعه وانا نفسيته كتير كنت مقتنعه
وانا يعني ما طلبت من حدا يطلعني ترند ولا
اعلنت عن هذا الاشي انا لما تحجبت تحجبت
لربنا مش عشان حدا ولا عشان حدا يطلعني
ترند
الحمد لله تحجبت والامور تمام بعدين صرت
احس انه الناس كتير يعني انه عم بتقيدني
انه ما بتغني انا ما بقدر اتخلى عن الغناء
انا بغني يعني انه ما تغني وانت وانت
متحجبه ايدك مبينه مثلا
رقبتك مبينه اشي حسيت حالي كتير متقيده
يعني هاي مش سالي انا حدا ابسط من هيك
يعني ما كنت متوقعه انه انه الموضوع
الحجاب مسؤوليه واكيد وهذا قرار شخصي برجع
لك يعني احنا في صدد النقاش فيك لكن اللي
بدي اقوله انه اكيد انت كنت متابعه غيرك
من مشاهير السوشيال ميديا في صبايا كتير
تحجبوا وبعدين شلحوا الحجاب وتعرضوا
لحملات تنمر والانتقادات كبيره ما كان
هدفي حس بانك قبل ما تاخذي قرار انه اتح
جبه ومن ثم اخلع الحجاب هلا انا لما شلحت
الحجاب ما كنتش خايفه غير من ربنا بصراحه
ما خفتش من كلام الناس نهائيا ما كنت
خايفه من كلام الناس والله يسامحني يعني
فيديوهات عليها ملايين المشاهدات وحذفتها
حذفت عشان بدي اتحجب
اقسم بالله انا لما تحجبت من قلبي تحجبت
انا لما تحجبت
من قلبي تحجبت
تمام
لكن البني ادم بغير قراراته
انا بني ادمه زيكم
[موسيقى]